there was an attempt by some people to
drum up a campaign to get me fired from
my University and I think people had
really learned from the Kathleen stock
incidents because not only did my
University very quickly reassure me that
I was not in any danger there was also
very very public support from senior
colleagues and from professors and other
academics at other institutions coming
out very very vocally and I think some
of that was just a commitment from
people who are working in my field to
defend academic freedom but I think some
of it will be people who might have felt
guilty about not doing the same thing
when it happened to Kathleen star